Hello, everyone. Happy Monday. Here we are Monday again. Hope everybody had a good weekend.
All right, so a few people are on. I'm gonna share the screen here. Here we go.
We'll start right in on the questions. So we've got the first one that came in.
Excuse me. I have an MRI scheduled for Friday. I also will be scheduling a massage. I've started
the gadolinium drops already. Is it better to schedule the massage for a few weeks after the MRI?
So I have had time to clear some of the gadolinium from my system before getting the massage
or schedule the massage right away after the MRI to help clear the gadolinium from my system.
So I don't see a problem with scheduling the massage right you know close to
after your massage. I don't know if you would be getting it you know immediately after or
you know the day after but certainly I don't see a problem in getting a massage
closely after just to help get the lymphatic system moving and you know really to help
just get it through the system and detox it. I will say that you want to make sure
you know you're continuing to support all of your organs of detoxification and so certainly
want to make sure that you're not constipated you know all of the things that we kind of talk about
when we talk about detoxing so yeah just take continue to take those gadolinium drops and make
sure you're not constipated stay hydrated drink a lot of water and you certainly can schedule a
massage shortly after your MRI and you could do another one in a couple weeks too so massage is
just a great way to relax but then also it is you know mechanically moving muscles which does
stimulate the lymphatic system the lymphatic system is you know part of getting rid of toxins getting
rid of waste emptying them back into the circulatory system you know so we can get rid of them through
our digestive tract so so you can do multiple massages okay I am confused and curious about the
clinic's new address did the clinic and everyone move to Wisconsin do you still see patients at the
clinic ever and if you're still in Minnesota what and who is in Wisconsin so good question so yes
we are in Wisconsin we are no longer in Minnesota we do not have the Lake Elmo clinic anymore the
least was up there we decided not to renew it you know it was a big space and just with kind of
doing more things virtually with COVID but also just kind of the future of where things are kind of
heading we decided we didn't need to renew such a big space so we have moved to Wisconsin so we
have two addresses so we have a warehouse which is where we have all of the supplements and also all
the supplements are shipping out of the warehouse and we do have some some office space if we want to
be working at the warehouse or certainly we can work from home as well so we have the address for
the warehouse that's where all of the cheek swabs we are asking that you send cheek swabs to the
warehouse because somebody is here at the warehouse Monday through Friday so grabbing mail and obviously
again shipping out supplements and then we also have a clinic so we still do thermography we still
have some therapies set up and once in a while people will schedule a pickup of supplements really
only if they're coming to do coming to do a therapy or something we have limited hours here right now
we are only at the physical clinic on Tuesdays usually Tuesdays after Tuesday afternoon so that's when
we schedule a little of our thermography appointments and we have some standing patients who are coming in
for some therapy so that's where we do that so that's this address here so we have the Revard street
in the sweet number 300 so that's the physical clinic and the warehouse is where we do all of shipping
and then we want the cheek swabs coming here so yes it can be confusing sorry about that it's
hopefully that cleared everything up and here is not a question but a resource that somebody wanted
to share so thank you we love it when people share resources she's founded to be very helpful with
the emotional work she heard about this from another cancer survivor investigated tried it for herself
and has been impressed with the results so it's a book the Healing Code by Dr. Alexander Lloyd and Dr.
Ben Johnson so I've highlighted the name of it and the authors here up top in yellow she encourages
everyone to buy the book you can find use copies on eBay and other sites for about five dollars these
men are Christian the medicine is energy the cost is free and the results are astounding I didn't
know for sure the effects the codes are having on my cancer but the impact on my emotional health
and anxiety and therefore my stress at a cellular level I believe is undeniable I don't understand how
it works any more than I understand how the right machine or even aspirin works but clearly it's
doing something just thought I'd put that out there so people can investigate if they're looking for
ways to address this need in my case I believe it's been even more effective than counseling and certainly
as much cheaper which is a huge bonus absolutely so thank you so much for sharing this again the name
of the book and the author is up top yeah check it out I'm gonna check it out myself we also do have
a book and a workbook available on our website it's called Braving the Storm so it is about the
emotional component of a diagnosis and just working through whether it's past trauma or just the
trauma from the diagnosis itself so working through those emotions surrounding a health crisis
and again could be relating to past experiences and then the workbook is you know it's it's action
you know taking action answering questions jotting things down to work through some of these emotions
and then the the author of Braving the Storm book and workbook has a group program it's called
uplifted let us know if you want that information but I know a number of our patients are part of the
uplifted program so it's you know it's it's group sessions virtual group sessions led by a practitioner
so somebody who's obviously trained in you know counseling and specific to cancer diagnosis so that
is another option but definitely check out this book the healing code I'm gonna check it out as well
all right and thank you for that I am flying for the first time since being on my
protocol I'm guessing that I don't want the supplements in my carry on to be x-rayed during
the screening process is that correct does x-ray damage supplements so even if you're you're
packaging them in your checked luggage it still does get x-rayed so either way if you're traveling
and bring them with you it still will be x-rayed so to my knowledge x-ray doesn't really damage
supplements um you know supplements aren't you know living tissues you know x-ray obviously can
cause DNA damage cellular damage but I don't know that it will will damage supplements but either way
if you check it or carry it on it's going to go through the x-ray and so certainly if you want to
just bring it with you on a carry on that way you're not going to be losing them if they lose your
luggage for some reason I would I would just carry them on and exciting flying going somewhere hopefully
you're going somewhere for a fun vacation any recommendations for a waterproof bandage to keep the
blacks have area on her breast dry while at the beach I don't plan to swim but I do plan to
wait in the water and walk along the water's edge so I don't have a specific bandage um you know
recommendation anything that is waterproof and you know big enough to cover the area I'm not sure
how big it is but um anything should work and just do the best that you can some of the waterproof
bandages tend to be a little more sticky so just be careful when you're removing it um and again
just make sure it's big enough so the sticky parts are not on the tender areas so
and again this is the same person so she's going to a beach so therapy beach therapy so that's
wonderful I hope you have a great trip okay I asked Dr. Conner's on the Wednesdays and call but he
didn't answer what natural thing I could take for pain just said that it was okay to take ibuprofen
if I didn't do it every day but now it's every day so excuse me sorry to hear that
that the pain is daily and no you're you're struggling with that and we are praying for you
I've listed here or copied some images you know just from our store of options and really you know
we don't know the one magical thing there is no magical thing for for pain everybody is different
but these are some options that you can try we do have patients who are taking evolve limitless
so this is made from um you know the medicinal component in beets so beets are very healthy
but beets can be high in sugar so this company has patented the betaline that is the act of component
in beets they've patented so it's concentrated and you're not getting the sugar and it's it works
as an anti-inflammatory so you could try this a lot of um people are taking it you know for menstrual
cramps or things like that and it can help just you know work for pain work as an anti-inflammatory
clear and flamm is another supplement that we have so this is taking a number of herbs and
things that have anti-inflammatory components and combining them all so it works synergistically
to really attack inflammation sometimes you have to take a lot of these capsules in order to kind of
get get control kind of get ahead of the inflammation which can be causing the pain and so you might
have to take a lot of them you know all supplements and constituents have a half-life within the body
and so you know you might need to take it multiple times throughout the day if you just have you know
a little bowl set out with some of the clear and flamm dumped into it you know take two every
take two you know you can I don't know every hour every couple hours just see how you do
curcuclear is another anti-inflammatory there is turmeric or curcumin in the clear and flamm this is
just the curcumin component so a lot of people can find find this is a great help for
inflammation once in a while this can cause digestive upset some diarrhea and some patients so
you know if if that happens you might need to back off we have this pain CBD oil so it is obviously
CBD you know which can help with anxiety stress relaxation which can just put you in a more calm state
but then it's also got other components other herbs that are helpful for pain as well
so you can try any of these and see see what might work certainly there's programs on the
right machine for pain I know you're aware of that and I think some of them haven't really been
very successful for you but anything for inflammation anything for pain on the right
machine could be helpful as well okay I show a variant at the beginning of making glutathione
naturally as well at the end of it how does a coffee animal work to increase glutathione seems to
me that the only way of increasing glutathione would be through an IV or liposomal glutathione
so with the coffee animals so there's a component to the coffee animal for liver detoxification
the caffeine in the coffee dilates the bile ducts in the liver which help facilitate elimination of trapped
toxins within the liver so when anytime we're helping dump those trapped toxins out of the liver
we are making room for other toxins to come into the liver so our body can work on those
so it's just facilitating this process getting rid of the things that might be stuck
and working to detox those things also involved in blood purification so when we're introducing
liquids into the colon the colon is designed to absorb liquids and so that's how we create stool it's
ultimately waste from digestion and the colon is extracting the water from it so it's forming the
hard stool for waste and so when we're introducing the liquid into the colon your colon is going to absorb
some of that liquid and the palmetic acid within the coffee is the key thing that we're wanting
wanting to be absorbed so that it's it's a powerful detoxifier it works directly to stimulate
glutathione the GST gene is glutathione s transferase and so this is an enzyme that is stimulated
by the palmetic acid in coffee and it increases production of glutathione by 700 percent in the
liver which is huge and so that is how the coffee or the coffee anava is stimulating glutathione
production and then also anytime that you're working to you know help facilitate getting
toxins out of the body you're reducing the the need for glutathione so you're kind of working
coffee animals are kind of working to spare glutathione because when you're getting rid of those
toxins that are stored in the liver you don't need as much glutathione because you're getting rid
of those excess toxins but then you're also stimulating the production you're stimulating that gene
which creates the enzyme glutathione that is directly related to binding on to toxins and getting
them out of the system so we're sparing the need for glutathione and we're increasing glutathione
production by by using the coffee animal. All right and the next question was from a food perspective
icy problem such as eating certain foods recommended with the AK but not recommended on a low
histamine diet does that mean I should supplement before eating any food to offset the possible
variant so yes this is confusing for a lot of people and you know our intention is not to be
confusing but sometimes sometimes things get confusing so we may have recommended you know your
normal you know a diet and maybe you know eliminate dairy eliminate red meat or something like that and
then with genetics we've also now added oh you have variants and some of your important genes that
help us to get rid of excess histamines whether in the tissue or whether in the digestive tract
and so based on that we've now added the recommendation of being on a low histamine diet and we may
have added a supplement like histoclear you know the the DAO enzyme or remind of added histamine
scavenger natural clear hist so so it does get confusing because some of the original dietary
recommendations conflict with the low histamine diet recommendations and so remember the goal
anytime we're recommending a low histamine diet or to avoid high histamine foods the goal is not
to eliminate every source of histamine because that is not possible the goal is just to reduce the
burden so your body can catch up so your body can do the work to read to get rid of the histamines your
body is just a slower processor of histamines and so if we are burdened by it we can again get that
backlog and so we need to to ease up on that to give our body a chance to catch up so we can do that
by eliminating high histamine foods so if we've told you to to eliminate those foods we've outlined them
they are available in your binder or when we made the recommendation we gave you the list of
some of the high histamine foods not all of them but just some of the major ones that we want you to
limit or avoid so you certainly can just do that if we have and in that portion of it trumps anything
that would would have originally been outlined in your diet so for example chocolate is probably
listed as one of the foods that you should avoid if you're on you know you're trying to eliminate some
histamines but chocolate may have been marked as a yes you can have that in your original dietary
guide with us but now the histamine foods the high histamine foods that we want you to limit are
trumping your original recommendation so now your recommendation is to not have chocolate
if chocolate is your thing that you know you just it makes you so happy you can imagine living
life without chocolate then yes a supplement would be something that you should take when you're
eating chocolate to provide your body with the environment to help break down a process that
histamine that is in that food and sometimes we we want you to do both we want you to lower the
histamines in your food from a dietary perspective and we do want you to take a supplement because
um yeah maybe your genes are really bad in that area so we want to just attack it you know
really hard and it might not have to be that way forever but for now we're just going to really
attack this histamines can be a driver for cancer histamines can create inflammation within the body
they can create a leaky gut scenario so histamines are not so great for some people
so really looking at genetics is important so but yes if we have recommended a supplement eat that
before any foods that you will be consuming that you know of histamines and you might even need to
be doing it even if you're not eating some of those high histamine foods to again just provide the
environment where your body is able to catch up okay so that kind of brought us through the questions
that were submitted through the form um through the zoom call form so now I'm going to take a look at
the chats let me see here um okay does reducing h h pylori was under the impression that iron
supplements aren't good for cancer this iron top is the iron uh tonic different so yes so anytime
there's an issue with iron and we have cancer we're kind of in a catch 22 situation so
we've talked about um iron can be a fuel source for cancer um but we cannot go we cannot obviously
iron is essential for living and so depending on where your iron levels are at by looking at lab
work you know we kind of assess okay do we need to supplement do we need an iron infusion
you know so where are we at so we really need to take a look at everybody from an individual
perspective when we are recommending iron for this person specifically we did recommend the iron
tonic it is different than um some of the iron supplements not in that it's a different form of iron
but just that it has some additional things that can work as a cancer fighter while you're taking the
iron because um I guess that iron can be a fuel source for cancer um but we can't live without iron
and so we're in this predicament and so we need to make you know we need to get just some iron for
the bodily function but we're trying to do it in a way where we're minimizing um the cancer from
you know consuming the iron and we want your healthy cells to get the iron so we like to
couple it with a cancer fighter um sometimes it's art omission sometimes it's other things other
cancer fighters so dr Conner's this iron tonic that this person is asking about is something
brand new so dr Conner's just came across this supplement I think that same day that he had this
consultation with this patient and so he has recommended this iron tonic um which has cancer fighters
in it as well so that's what he would like you to take um and hopes that your healthy cells are
gonna uptake this iron and if the cancer cells uptake it as well which they are likely to but there's
cancer fighting properties within it as well um so we'll just monitor and take close attention
how do you know if hpilora is being reduced um so that's a good question and I don't know if you
you can do I'm assuming you can do some tests to check to see if hpilora is present um if you have
an hpilora infection I don't know assuming it would be a stool test um but it's well hpilora is
something that is normal it's you know a normal inhabitant of the gut environment and it's just
when it gets out of balance that it's not good and it can it is the leading cause of stomach cancer
so how do we know if it's being reduced well you're you're doing all the things to reduce it we're
you're taking the supplements that we know combat um hpilora we're writing programs on the right
machine that are related you know to hpilora so um so without a test you know we don't really know
for sure um but we're doing all the things that we know of to keep this in balance um okay
oh that's okay so somebody just kind of mistyped the first question and retyped it and then said
sorry not good at this that's okay I'm not checking anybody's spelling and I can can interpret
you know the gits of a question I know people are either on their phones or they're on their
computers and trying to listen and multi-tasking so so no worries any other questions let's see here
oh you're welcome yes I know I I can relate trying to type a question in quick and listen
it's a lot all right any other questions for me so as as usual um just kind of a screenshot of the
membership site to free reminder for you guys to visit here often um we are updating it I think
there's some new information on the zoom call page Dr. Conner's added kind of a little a little
header for people to read just to kind of reiterate um the purpose of the zoom calls and um you know
to kind of stay in our lane a little bit unfortunately we are being forced to I mean you know we don't
want to stray from our lane of natural health but we are you know um being monitored you know
Dr. Conner's has said this on previous zoom calls so it's not a secret but we're just trying to you
know conform and really kind of stick to some rules here um so we can keep our mission and ministry
alive um just by being a little more strict on some of these rules as it comes as it pertains to
you know um medical questions and seeking advice for for medical care we just really can't
um cross that line or tiptoe that line um because we want to be able to keep doing what we're doing
and keep our our mission going and help as many people as we can from a natural perspective
you know with the rife with supplements with um dietary advice with genetics um so these are kind
of uh that's our our lane so any questions regarding to those things are fair game and appropriate
for the zoom calls and we just are asking that you know we we unfortunately can't answer the the
questions pertaining to medications or uh conventional care we just have to be more strict on that
any other questions for me if not a little bit of a short call today um hopefully everybody
like I said had a good weekend we'll have a good week um send us more questions Dr. Conner's will
be answering on on Wednesday and I do have a number of patients where I sent out genetic uh information
so reminder that if you haven't had your genetic review yet you are invited to the third day to
PM genetic review zoom call where you can ask questions um somebody had questions um that she wasn't
sure these ones were about genetics and um so she wasn't sure so I included them obviously on
this one because they do pertain um coffee animals pertain to to um protocol and they pertain to
genetics as well so just send us your questions and um certainly jump on that genetic specific one if
you do have some more genetic detailed questions all right everyone I don't think any more chats came
in so we will sign off for today everybody have a good day and we will be connecting throughout the
week and then of course um next Monday all right take care we're praying for you guys bye bye